devant la chapelle une forêt de lens
tenu par les membres de la confrérie de
la saint-roch
ils n'ont aujourd'hui rien à voir avec
la religion ils font en fait partie
d'une équipe amateur de joutes nautiques
et ont relancé il ya cinq ans une fête
séculaire qui avait disparu avec des
filets sur terre et duel sur lui il a
une tradition qui existe depuis 1900 ou
ici le port de saint thibault était
prisé par des mariniers car il
descendait beaucoup à orléans déposé le
20 donc pour trouver le capitaine des
bateaux il y avait une confrontation
entre capitaine de bateau sur deux
barques comme ici pour savoir qui allait
qui allait conduire les bateaux jusqu'à
voler sur les bateaux des enfants
attirés par cette tradition et ce sport
comme elena 9 ans meilleures joueuses de
la saison dans sa catégorie elle
maîtrise le port de la lance et bat ses
adversaires depuis l'arrière de
l'embarcation appelé trinquet il ajouté
avant c'était ça me faisait peur parce
que pour moi c'était comme si avec un
bâton tu te garer mais maintenant pour
moi c'est non
je quand je manque un trinquet je suis
contente pour moi juste trop bien mais
le choc semble quelque peu violent
une rencontre où les bateaux font trois
tonnes au total donc au niveau de
l'impact
ça fait quand même assez costaud que ça
soit pour des enfants des adultes dans
cette compétition amicale
cinq clubs qui comptent parmi eux les
meilleurs jouteurs de l'année et si
champion de france encore s'il est ici
le côté festif
ils viennent aussi pour combattre sur la
loire et non sur un canal comme ils en
ont l'habitude
jeandupeux les bateaux sont beaucoup
plus loin il ya beaucoup plus au courant
que nous change un peu plus souvent que
d'habitude
frédéric elena participeront au
championnat de france à melun fin août
ceux qui n'y vont pas comme thibaut
prentice hiller revanche qu'il pleuve ou
qu'il mouille